what do you think
i have to ask you about the movie her
let's do a movie review
what do you uh what do you think they
got they did a good job
what do you think they did a bad job of
portraying about this experience of um
of a voice based assistant that you can
have a relationship with
first of all i started working on this
company before that movie came out
so it was a very but once it came out it
was like actually
interesting i was like well we're
definitely working on the right thing
we should continue there are movies
about it and then you know smoking
came out and all these things in the
movie her i think that's
the most important thing that people
usually miss about the movie
um is the ending because i think people
check out when the ai's leave
but actually something really important
happens afterwards
because the main character goes and
talks to samantha
he's um ai um
oh yeah and he says something like you
know
uh how can you leave me i've never loved
anyone
the way i loved you and she goes uh well
me neither but now we know how
and then the guy goes and writes a
heartfelt letter to his
ex-wife which he could write for you
know the whole movie he was struggling
to
actually write something meaningful to
her even although that's his job
um and then he goes and
um talk to his neighbor and they go to
the rooftop and they cuddle and
it seems like something's starting there
and so i think this now we know how
is the is the main main goal is the main
meaning of that movie
it's not about falling in love with the
os or running away from other people
it's about
learning what you know what it means to
feel so
deeply connected with something
what about the thing where the ai system
was like
actually hanging out with a lot of
others
i felt jealous just like hearing that i
was like oh i mean
uh yeah so she was having
i forgot already but she was having like
deep meaningful discussion with some
like philosopher guy
like alan watts or something like
what kind of deep meaningful
conversation can you have with alan
watts in the first place yeah i know but
like i would
i would feel so jealous that there's
somebody who's like
way more intelligent than me and she's
spending all her time with
i'd be like well why that i won't be
able to live up to that
that's thousands of them uh
is that um is that useful from the
engineering perspective
the feature to have of jealousy
i don't know as you know we definitely
played around with the replica universe
where different replicas can talk to
each other the universe is so awesome it
was just
kind of it wouldn't i think it will be
something along these lines but there
was just no
specific application straight away
i think in the future again if i'm
always thinking about it
if we had no tech limitations uh right
now
if we could build any conversations any
possible features in this product then
yeah i think different replicas talking
to each other would be also quite cool
because that would help us
connect better you know because maybe
mine could talk to yours and then give
me some suggestions on
what i should say or not say i'm just
kidding but like more
can it improve our connections and
because eventually
i'm not quite yet sure that we
will succeed that our thinking is
correct um
because there might be reality where
having a perfect
ai friend still makes us more
disconnected from each other and there's
no way around it
and does not improve any metrics for us
uh real metrics meaningful metrics so
success
is you know we're happier and more
connected
yeah i don't know
sure it's possible there's a reality
that's i i'm deeply optimistic
i think are you worried
business-wise like how difficult it is
to um to bring this thing to life to
where it's
i mean there's a huge number of people
that use it already but to uh yeah like
i said in a multi-billion dollar
company is that a source of stress for
you
are you uh super optimistic and
confident
or do you i don't i'm not that much of a
numbers person as you probably
have seen it so it doesn't matter for me
whether like whether we help 10 000
people or
a million people or a billion people
with that um
i'd it would be great to scale for more
people but
i'd say that even helping one i think
with this
is such a magical yeah for me it's
absolute magic i never thought that
and you know would be able to build this
that anyone would ever
um talk to it and i always thought like
well for me we'll be successful if we
manage to help and
actually change a life for one person
like then we did something interesting
and you know how many people
can say they did it and specifically
with this very futuristic very romantic
technology so that's how i view it
uh i think for me it's important to to
try to figure out how not
how to actually be you know helpful
because
in the end of the day if you can build a
perfect ai friend that's
so understanding that knows you better
than any human out there
can have great conversations with you um
always knows how to make you feel better
why would you choose another human
you know so that's the question how do
you still keep building it so it's
optimizing for the right thing
so it's still circling you back to other
humans in a way
so i think that's the main um maybe
that's the main kind of sort
source of anxiety and just thinking
about
i think about that can be a little bit
stressful yeah it's a fascinating thing
how to have a heart of a friend
that doesn't like sometimes like friends
quote unquote
or like you know those people who have
when they like guy in the guy
universe when you have a girlfriend that
uh
you get the girlfriend and then the guy
stops hanging out with all of his
friends
[Laughter]
it's like obviously the relationship
with the girlfriend is
fulfilling or whatever but like you also
want it to be what she like
makes it more enriching to hang out with
the guy friends or whatever it was
up there anyway that that's uh
that's a that's a that's a fundamental
problem in choosing the right mate
and probably the fundamental problem
creating the right ai
system right
you